JENNY BROWN: When it comes
to gaming, whether it's
action, RPG or simulation,
staying in the action
means being online.
But in the offline world, you
rep your fandom with merch.
Will Critter Junction's
e-commerce shop
be able to handle their hype?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Without any
in-person conventions
this year, Critter Junction
players from around the world
have begun to flood their
site to purchase character
cards, apparel, and other swag.
Critter Junction has been
testing App Engine standard
to run their new
merchandise shop,
Because App Engine auto
scaled their application
across multiple instances
to meet the demands
of additional traffic.
But during load testing,
they used Cloud Trace
to measure response latency.
And they noticed a
higher than usual latency
when they used heavier
concurrent requests
to their service's
HTTP end point.
You see, pending
latency is how long
a request can be
sitting in the queue
before App Engine decides
to spin up another instance.
If all of your app instances
are busy when a request arrives,
the request will wait
in a queue to be handled
by the next available instance.
As the load increases,
this means requests
are processed more slowly.
App Engine will then
start a new instance
to help based on limits you
set, like CPU utilization,
throughput, and max
concurrent requests
of the current
running instances.
But what they didn't know
is that App Engine also
needs to load their app's code
into a fresh instance when they
redeploy a new
version of their app,
and when maintenance and repairs
of underlying infrastructure
or physical hardware occur.
Though cold starts on
App Engine are rare,
the first request or loading
request sent to a new instance
can take longer to be processed,
because the instance first
has to load your
app's code, including
any libraries and resources
needed to handle the request.
This means a gradual
increase in response times
to handle new traffic.
What you want instead is
to get the initialization
to happen sooner, before a new
instance serves live traffic.
You can do this by using
a warmup request, which
loads application code into
an instance ahead of time,
before any live
requests reach it.
App Engine attempts
to detect when
your app needs a new instance
and initiates a warmup
request to initialize it.
Any new instances
accept requests
after they finish
loading your app's code.
New requests can then
be handled faster.
Warmup requests are used by
the App Engine scheduler, which
controls auto-scaling
of instances
based on your configuration.
App Engine issues get
requests to /_ah/warmup.
And then you can implement
handlers for this request
in your code to perform
application-specific tasks,
like pre-caching app data.
For most supported languages,
just add the warmup element
under the inbound
services directive
in your app.yaml file.
Then create a handler
that will process requests
that are sent to ah.warmup.
Your handler should
perform any warmup logic
that is needed by your app.
Let's walk through a Go example.
Our function performs
the required setup steps
for the application
to function, and it
logs when an App Engine
warmup request is used
to create the new instance.
These warmup steps happen
in setup for consistency
with cold start instances.
Everything else
remains the same.
This setup function executes
the per instance one-time warmup
and initialization actions.
Finally, the index
handler responds
to requests with our greeting.
One thing to note
is warmup requests
don't work in all cases,
despite the best-effort attempt
to send requests to
already warmed-up instances
when enabled.
So you might still
face loading requests,
like if the instance is the
first one being started up
or if there's a steep
ramp-up in traffic.
In these cases, you should use
the resident instances, which
you can learn about below.
Once warmup requests
were implemented,
Critter Junction was able to
reduce cold start instances
during increases in traffic
to their online shop
once convention
season was underway.
Stickers for everyone!
Check out the link below
for language-specific steps
on warmup requests, and
stay tuned for what's
next for Critter Junction.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]